I know what you're wondering what's in
the canister I could tell you
then I'd have to kill you I'm only
mocking about relax as for what's in the
canister it's best he done us
amateurs with in a life-threatening
situation the average person's heartbeat
can be upwards of 100 75 beats
informated the well-trained tango say
but as they cool keep calm
there are rates can be 70 to 100 beats
per minute but by the time I'm done that
number goes down to zero
I've learned from experience that the
place to save lives is in the field not
an office
and sometimes the only way to save a
life is to take one
I trust that the ceramic trauma plate
I'm wearing will stop a 357 magnum round
traveling at 490 meters per second I
trust myself not to move not to flinch
I trust my teammates
and they trust me
these soldiers think their training will
keep them alive they break down doors
and come through windows weapon strong
but it still wait
they forgot this first to destroy a real
hunter always watches where he steps
they said it could not be done they said
it was designed for tanks they said I
could not make it smaller and more
accurate I used to be undercover at a
time
I have to deal drugs I even had to kill
and I was so good at it that it got me a
promotion
you